hi it's my name is jabron zahed i'm a
researcher at microsoft research working
in the immunomix group and today i'm
going to be telling you about how we are
working to learn learning how to read
the adaptive immune system
this project is a deep collaboration
between adaptive biotechnologies and
microsoft in which we are trying to
bring the science of immunology uh
together with the power of the
computational power of artificial
intelligence in order to build uh better
care for healthcare using
what we call immunosequencing so we're
learning to decode the immune system to
diagnose diseases and this really
requires several steps and a deep
expertise coming from the two
organizations so the first step of this
is we need to draw blood samples from
individuals and so we take a vial of
blood from
donors
and we do what's called immunosequencing
this is really the expertise of adaptive
biotechnologies
they take
hundreds of thousands to millions of t
cells and sequence genetically
the
t cell receptor and on our side in terms
of the data we get genetic sequences of
the t cell receptor
using these data we apply sophisticated
machine learning techniques in order to
try to learn
how to
decode the immune system using these
genetic sequences and these
uh the techniques that we develop and
the diagnostics we're developing
hopefully lead to uh empowerment of
healthcare for
humans
so here's the expertise stack that we're
working with in which
you can there's a deep expertise in
terms of the immunology coming from
adapters so we have an immunologist and
clinicians who are deeply involved in
getting the data and
in in terms of sequencing it and that
speeds into the computational biologists
who begin the analysis and then on the
microsoft side we have
the ai researchers who are working to
understand these massive data sets and
there's a back and forth as you can see
the data flows down from adaptive
algorithms and models flow from
microsoft and it's actually quite a
synergistic process of um building out
this uh diagnostic platform
and so to start with i'd like to discuss
the immunology and how it all works so
how do t cells actually learn to do uh
to learn uh
about pathogens
so the
immunology starts with
a bunch of t cells
and then there's the human cells and
those cells themselves have viruses or
can be infected by viruses so there's
genetic material inside the cell here
and so that genetic material gets broken
up into little pieces it gets chopped up
inside a cell and that then gets
transported to the surface of the cell
via what's known as these molecules
known as hoas
so if something like a virus comes in
the virus itself will get chopped up
here's the covet 19
virus for example and then it will get
um
transported to the surface now if
there's a t cell in this bunch of t
cells that recognizes this little piece
of the virus
it will initiate an immune response and
it'll clonally expand
and this is really the critical
ingredient
in our ability to
use build diagnostics based on t cell
immunology
so the specificity uh is determined by
the t cell receptor so this tcr bit is
what we actually sequence at uh what
adaptive biotechnology sequences and
that completely determines what peptide
or what part of the
the virus uh what antigen a t cell will
respond to
that signal is clonally amplified
because of clonal expansion and that's
the signal that we can re we try to read
out so for a given disease you can have
tens of thousands of these t-star t
cells responding to hundreds of antigens
so the virus gets broken up creates all
these antigens and various t cells
respond to those antigens
to give you a sense of the challenge of
the problem let's take a look at the
numbers so it's currently believed that
there's something on the order of 10 to
the 15 possible t cells the t cells are
produced via a quasi-random process
and of those t cells any given
individual any human will have on the
order of billions in their body just
floating around not all of them will be
unique because of his clonal expansion
so on the order of millions of unique
tcrs
of those we sample using the amino
sequencing amino sequence on the order
of 100 000 to a million of these
billions of t cells and we refer to this
as the repertoire
of those for any given disease like
covid we anticipate on the order of one
thousand to ten thousand t cells are
specific to actually covalent are
responding to that virus other t cells
may have responded to other illnesses in
the past some may not be have responded
to any illness at all thus far
and then of those the signal we really
leverage is the shared signal the signal
that we can see the t cells we see
amongst many many different individuals
who all have the same disease
so
this is really a new approach to
diagnostics
given the t cell repertoire can we
predict disease
and the answer is absolutely
and we've done that with covid
so
we are able to using this technology
detect a past coded infection
so here
is our basic signal the way the setup
works is we have a case control setup we
have let's say on the order of thousand
individuals that we know have covered
and a thousand individuals in our
control sample that we don't know do not
have cover and we just ask the question
are there more individuals
are there t cells in these individuals
that have covariate that occur in a
statistically higher frequency than the
individuals who don't and those t cells
are the ones that we anticipate are
responding to the back virus and so for
covid we have something like 10 000 t
cells we think are responding to the
covert virus and the diagnostic is
essentially asking the question
how many of these 10 000 t cells does
any one individual have and so what this
plot shows is on our sample of holdout
patients people who weren't involved in
deriving the diagnostic
the
signal so
this axis the y-axis shows the number of
sequences each of these individuals has
and the x-axis here shows the
depth of the sequencing because the
sequencing depth does vary
for various reasons but the upshot of
all of this is that the orange points
are people who have coveted and the blue
points are people who don't so people
who have covet have elevated counts of
these sequences and the most important
one of the most interesting aspects of
this is we have many many cohorts
spanning many continents and many uh
different countries many different
racial groups and regardless of where
they come from
we see that we're able to
diagnose and discriminate individuals
who have coveted from people who don't
so what this means is we have the
ability potentially to build universal
diagnostics for detecting diseases
here this plot shows or this table shows
that the sensitivity of our diagnostic
increases as a day since the infection
so you know our highest it takes a while
to mount the infection but then once we
get to something like two three weeks in
the diagnostic out to several months
or the signal out to several months is
quite good this is the sensitivity of
our ability to tell whether someone has
the disease or not and so what this
really says is we can use this
technology to understand
past infections of diseases and so if
we're as we build out this platform and
start detecting more and more diseases
we'll able we hope that we will be able
to read their immune history of
individuals
so one of the key
aspects of all of this is
we don't actually know given the way we
do our
diagnostics where we look at case
control setup whether the actual t cell
is responding to something in the virus
but we have a separate set of
experiments that allow us to begin to
understand that question in these sets
of experiments we take a bunch of the
virus chop it up into pieces as we think
the body would and in the presentation
step within a cell and then we throw a
bunch of t cells at it and ask which t
cells are sticking and what this plot
shows on the x axis is the genome of the
co of covid and then the orange for
example the surface
protein is the spike protein region of
that genome and these blue
bars are basically showing where we are
able where we have t cells hitting the
virus so these are candidate t cells
that are responding to the actual
antigens and now we know the antigens
because we've chosen the antigens that
we presented and what's exciting is that
using this technique combined with the
case control setup that i described we
are now able to convincingly demonstrate
that we are actually hitting the
antigens that we think we are because
we can separate out and identify which
tcrs are hitting which antigens and here
is a really interesting example of
demonstrating the the validity of this
so what's being shown here is
this is again our signal versus um our
signal plot as i showed before but this
also has vaccine recipients on it so
these people in red are people who've
received the vaccine now for covid the
vaccines only target the spike protein
and as a consequence we would only
expect a immune response targeting spike
and so when we separate out the t cells
that are specific to spike this is what
it looks like and indeed people with
vaccines separate from the blue controls
if we look at the rest of the response
which is not spark
we see that while the people who have a
natural infection do separate out from
the controls the individuals who've
received the vaccine no longer do it and
so what this is telling us is to some
degree of resolution we are able to
discriminate between individuals who had
a natural infection and vaccine and
therefore confirms that we are able to
identify t cells and the antigens that
they're responding to
ultimately the antigen map will be
a
we hope a
platform whereby we can take a t cell
recep a t cell repertoire not even know
the antigens infer the antigens because
given enough examples we will learn
given a t cell what antigen it responds
to and then eventually use that platform
to predict many many diseases including
cancers autoimmune disorders and various
infectious diseases
thank you very much